i am not saying that to say
that trans
women aren't women
i am just saying
that those that they got
you know what i mean
how you doing people
whether you are a man with male
genitalia a female with female genitalia
a male with female genitalia a female
with male genitalia a little of
everything or you got nothing if you're
a complete eunuch you are welcome here
on the reuben report i'm dave rubin it
is june 21st 2022 and we are all
everyone in this room is feeling a very
special show today today is going to be
a celebration of all things trans it is
coming it is here it is everywhere trans
celebration pride month the navy has
gone queer it's bananas people uh before
we get to that though uh in case you
forgot july 14th i'm gonna be at the
miami improv i hope to see you here in
the free state of florida in the great
city of miami you can get tickets at
daverubin.com
events and we are trying something a
little new today by the way uh for those
of you that are watching on rumble
we are going to be reading off some
rumble rants at the end of the show
normally we only use locals comments at
the end so of course we're going to
stick with our locals comments as always
so if you want to join the live chat you
can go to reubenreport.locals.com
but if you are watching on rumble and
you want to do a rumble rant
you can do that and we will read some
comments at the end but
more importantly than any of the
clerical stuff today is a tremendous
trans celebration here at the reuben
report and not only a trans celebration
a celebration of all things woke all
things collective all of the things that
we knew weren't true just a few years
ago that we now know are true today that
are being peddled by our political elite
and our mainstream media and everything
else so i'm very excited for the program
michael said that today's show is going
to be an 8.93
which was a very specific but positive
number uh phoenix really went high nine
five and then
uh connor who usually lowballs me uh
using the prices right method he said uh
nine six today so that's the type of
pressure that i'm up against but you
guys will be the judge in about 40
minutes from now real quick let's talk
about real estate agents i trust and
then get to it you know buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be ten times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment that's a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team makes the intro and
then follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied their agents of the agents
they work with have long track records
and are the best sellers in their field
they're part of this audience they share
your values and they're almost anywhere
you want to go including the free state
of florida the process is simple just go
to real estate agentsidetrust.com today
and provide them with some basic info
their team will contact you to make an
introduction to their preferred agent in
your town and then you move and then
you're happier that's how it works
people
okay so let's talk about what's going on
with this more than meets the eye
movement this trans movement that
seemingly is being pushed on us from
every corner of society right now of
course our cold open today
was from dave chappelle's last netflix
special and the reason that we threw to
that was because dave chappelle has been
pushing back against this woke trans
insanity for a while he is allowed to
make jokes about things what comedians
used to do back in the day was take a
topical issue
and poke fun at it using humor to
describe a truthful situation so that
people could think about things a little
bit differently that's what chappell's
been doing uh there aren't many other
comedians doing that these days but
chappelle was going to be honored uh by
his high school is going to be honored
by his high school but some people are
not very happy because dave chappelle is
a very very scary man we've got some
info from the daily wire dave chappelle
will be honored by his high school alma
mater after supporters reportedly
outnumbered critics in a fundraising
challenge issued after his transgender
jokes drew a backlash against netflix
chappelle was previously heckled by
students at the school who slammed him
for comments he made in his netflix
comedy special the closer the renaming
ceremony comes after the comedian issued
a challenge to supporters and critics to
donate to his alma mater and said
whichever side raises the most money
will determine whether or not the
theater would be named after him but he
requested if you don't care enough to
donate please shut the f up forever
okay so this is kind of beautiful here
you have chappelle making jokes about
stuff and by the way you should be able
to make jokes about stuff you know if we
said okay you can't make jokes about gay
people you can't make jokes about black
people you can't make jokes about trans
people or anything you'd have to
obliterate absolutely everything and by
the way we've been doing quite a job of
obliterating absolutely everything over
the last couple of years right we've
cancelled uh episodes of the golden
girls do you know this one i've
mentioned it once on the show before
there's an episode where rose and
blanche come out and they have mud on
their faces because they're doing
facials not that kind of facial the
other kind of facial and uh
and demonetized um and they the woman
claims that they're in blackface that's
the joke so they removed that from hulu
we've canceled so many things we got rid
of aunt jemima and we got rid of uncle
ben we took all the black people off the
products who was it was it the white
supremacists who did it no it was the
wokesters who did it uh but if you want
to go around in police comedy you're
gonna have to get rid of everything
you're gonna have to get rid of seinfeld
right jerry bought a statue of a native
american
to give to elaine one day they made some
indian jokes the aids ribbon like all so
you're gonna have to get rid of that
you're gonna have to get rid of every
simpsons episode you're gonna have to
get rid of family guy you have to get
rid of absolutely everything so
chappelle not only making the jokes but
then putting it to the people and he's
gonna he's gonna go forward and they're
they're gonna donate this money and it's
all good that's how you fight back uh
but it isn't just that this stuff is
hitting us culturally so the reason i
started with the chapel thing isn't that
uh that chappelle's special or what's
going on at his school is so important
but what's happening with the trans
thing that we i that we all seemingly
have to bow down to this that if you do
not accept that four-year-olds who feel
a different way a boy who feels a little
bit like a girl should be on puberty
blockers and on their way to becoming
the other gender
if you don't buy into all of that that
you're somehow a bigot or mean or
anything else well all of this nonsense
it's leaking into our military and this
video came out yesterday we're going to
show you a couple clips of it this is
absolutely insane this is from the u.s
navy i am not kidding you you're going
to be watching this in a second from now
and you're going to go dave that can't
be real this seems like amateur hour
from a high school
but this is the u.s navy
training its staff
to create a safe space
by using gender pronouns
take a look
hi my name is johnny and i use he him
pronouns hi and i am kanji and i use chi
her pronouns and we're here to talk
about pronouns
what is a pronoun a pronoun is how we
identify ourselves apart from our name
and it's also how people refer to us in
conversations using the right pronouns
is a really simple way to affirm
someone's identity it is a signal of
acceptance and respect instead of saying
something like hey guys you can say hey
everyone or hey team
yeah and now that you say that another
way that we could show that we're allies
and that we accept
everybody is to maybe include our
pronouns in our emails or like we just
did introduce ourselves using our
pronouns
oh there's more coming people and that's
real i know you're watching it you're
going that can't be real dave today is
not april fool's day don't punk us like
that but that is real that is a real
video that the u.s navy put out who are
those two people they don't even seem
like real people they seem like
automatons what is her accent it seems
like it's robotic and they're saying
things that have nothing to do with the
navy didn't the navy have something to
do with a bunch of guys getting in the
water and then going to save people
perhaps or we blow up something or
we got more i'm going to stay on screen
for this one because this is so insane
here we go and another tip
for you to remember their
pronoun next time it's in your mind kind
of go through a progression of three
good things about the person using their
pronouns so let's say the person
chooses to use day
then you will in your mind go
they have a nice shirt they have a nice
smile they are really smart so that kind
of sticks in your brain that is
listen
i gotta warn you people
there is collective brain damage
happening across the world right now
okay it's happening right in front of
our faces imagine imagine you're in the
navy imagine you come from a proud navy
family
right
i've been to annapolis where the naval
academy is i was at the naval academy
about a year ago took a walk around it's
really lovely place imagine you come
from a proud naval family and they are
subjecting you to that sheer drivel not
not only is it complete insanity it's
just complete insanity that has nothing
to do with nothing it has nothing
certainly nothing to do with the navy
being effective at what your job is
protecting this country making sure that
if a pirate ship is attacking another
ship that you're going to take care of
the other ship
it continues
just to share something with you that
happened uh the other day at akuka i was
at we were
talking about pronouns and somebody was
disagreeing with
how different people
see themselves as different pronouns and
the argument was if you look like a
female then it's chi her because that's
what's normal and if you make me call
you something else then you're
infringing on my rights
and i i was really taken aback by the
comment and i really wasn't sure
how to respond and the only thing i
could really think quickly to say was
it's not about you
at all
and
it's mostly and ultimately about respect
but if i were to tell you over and over
again my name is johnny
and you insist on mispronouncing my name
i would feel disrespected by you
some names are very difficult to
pronounce but do you know what is very
easy to pronounce
she he they
[Music]
let's be clear about something let's be
clear that's what joe biden says all the
time let's be clear she he them are
[ __ ] bananas those people are insane
you don't have to behave the way these
people want they're not real human
beings and what i mean by that is they
have no understanding of what it is to
get and earn respect and to be an adult
in a world that doesn't have to bow to
you a world that exists and then you do
your best within that world the fact
that this has leaked into our military
is so nuts but you also may be watching
this and going
dave you don't understand you're not a a
gen
z
you know you're not a millennial you're
not one of the young kids of the day
these these things are very important
the pronouns the she he the zazer all of
it it's very important you're you're old
man you're an old you're 45. i'm gonna
be 46 this sunday by the way it's my
birthday you're at old time right now
you don't understand the importance of
transsexual gender pronouns and the
thing is guys i learned about this i
learned about this years ago from the
original
transformers
prime come out and face me
unless you're afraid to be beaten by a
woman
those mouth-watering breasts aren't
fooling anyone megatron i'm still gonna
shoot you you should check your
privileged prime before one of my new
warriors checks it for you
behold
combot i'm sexy safe space
and blackboard yeah i'm just a black guy
i don't really want to be here yes you
do you're a minority start acting like
it
total sidebar if you want to watch a
great great movie uh instead of the
disastrous 17 michael bay transformer
movies that you can't understand a word
that they're saying and you know shia
labeouf is running away from some
computer generated monstrosity go see
the original 1985 transformers movie and
oh my god it is just absolute perfection
uh but joking aside there are some good
things happening because as i've just
shown you for these first 10 minutes i
mean there's just so we are just being
inundated with absolute drivel but
enough of us are starting to laugh at it
mock it and now in this case actually
fight against it so i am now going to
show you a video from california so i do
have to put money in the jar but this is
actually quite spectacular this is a
californian mother her name is aaron
friday and she's a lefty she's a liberal
she'll make the point in just a moment
um and she has basically had it with
what's going on related to all of the
gender nonsense and the fact that gavin
newsom psychopath gavin newsom wants
california to become a gender sanctuary
state so that kids in other
states can move there to have their
genitals and boobs cut off take a look
hi my name is erin friday i'm a democrat
and i voted for same-sex marriage i'm
one of the leads of our duty and parents
of our ogd kids there are thousands of
parents in our group
we are cheering on the states that are
starting stopping gender medicine on
children
parents in the state of california have
lost custody of their children merely by
calling their child by their legal name
sb 107 must not pass
custody is one of the hardest fought
aspects of a divorce and california
cannot just wipe away an out of state
agreement addressing which parent
controls the medical health of a child
scott weiner a man without children is
pushing gender affirmative medicine laws
for minors while other countries are
moving away from the affirmation model
the number of kids going to gender
clinics is skyrocketing
in the uk
it is a 5
000
uptick
for girls as seen in the graph
it's the same here
we parents know it's a social contagion
as we watch clusters of friend groups
come out as trans
it's not organic
if trans medicine prevents suicide
why then as trans medicine gets more
prevalent are more girls committing
suicide don't make california a refuge
for what will be seen as the largest
medical scandal in history
okay so there's obviously some serious
stuff here but the funny stuff first the
guy who is pushing this in california
he's a representative congressman a
democrat of course and as she said his
name is scott
weiner
weiner
the man who is creating a sanctuary
state for people
young children to come
and get their wieners chopped off is
named weiner
okay you see what's going on here uh
joking aside um this woman as she points
out she's a democrat so she's been
misguided politically let's say but she
voted for same-sex marriage she's
obviously not a bigot she is not a
racist person or a right-wing maniac or
alt-right she's probably not a trump
supporter or anything else she is a
liberal who has been mugged by reality
which is pretty much everyone in america
right now right all of the sort of
middle people who just thought oh the
liberalism the decent liberalism that we
had for these last 50 60 100 years in
america
if not more actually was going to just
keep working it has morphed into
something horrific and that thing that
it has morphed into is now fully and
wholly infected the democrat party which
is a why a guy by the name of scott
weiner
is now pushing for california to be a
sanctuary state for kids to come and
have their gender change and of course
you cannot actually change your gender
you can change your body but you cannot
change uh your
uh you cannot change your sex your
biological sex uh oh interestingly i'm
just seeing this right now thanks for
the heads up on this uh erin friday that
woman right there her daughter
detransitioned meaning her daughter
transitioned to become a boy and then at
some point along the road actually now
went back to being a girl
she also brings up these incredible
numbers these staggering staggering
statistics of this explosion of mostly
young girls that are becoming boys and
it usually is not young boys becoming
girls there are some instances of that 5
000
increase in the uk i mean this is
extraordinary stuff this is a social
contagion much more than a biological uh
inconsistency or problem and everyone
understands it and the fact that you
would do this to children
do this to children and again as i
pointed out on the show yesterday you
know if you think that everything can be
solved by science meaning if a young boy
really thinks he's a girl or a young
girl really thinks he's a boy if you
think everything could be saw by science
meaning give them puberty blockers give
them testosterone so they can be more
boyish give them
estrogen to be more gross why wouldn't
you if you have a young boy who wants to
be a girl maybe give him more
testosterone so he could maybe feel like
more of a man wouldn't that possibly
make more sense i'm not even saying it
does i don't i don't i honestly don't
understand the full science of all this
but what is the push for all this we all
know it's insane uh but there are some
sane people out there you know jordan
peterson he uh tweeted this i thought it
was quite succinct
california haven for the medical
butchery of miners and it really is as
simple as that that is what california
will become under gavin newsom they will
have eight month abortions uh so you'll
be killing children then you'll be
chopping off children's genitals
you will hire people based on the color
of their skin and the blue states will
just absolutely crumble and the red
states will will do their best to have
some semblance of sanity uh but what's
interesting about all of this is not
only what's happening sort of on the
ground with parents that are fighting it
it's how the media
covers all of the trans stuff
so we've got some info here uh from nbc
on what's going on in the swimming the
female
swimming category which we've talked a
bit about before
from nbc world swimming's governing body
effectively banned transgender athletes
from competing in women's events on
sunday
fina members at the organization's
extraordinary general congress voted 71
and a half percent in favor of its new
gender inclusion policy that only
permits swimmers who transition before
age 12 to compete in women's events
this is not saying that people are
encouraged to transition by the age of
12. it's what the scientists are saying
that if you transition after the start
of puberty you have an advantage which
is unfair james pierce who is the
spokesperson for fina president hussein
al-massalam told the associated press
they're not saying everyone should
transition by age 11. that's ridiculous
you can't transition by that age in most
countries and hopefully you wouldn't be
encouraged to basically what they're
saying is that it is not feasible for
people who have transitioned to compete
without having an advantage okay so you
guys know all about this we have shown
you the videos and the pictures of leah
thomas leah thomas who was a very
marginal male swimmer i think he was
ranked something like 425th in the
nation who started absolutely crushing
it and winning all of the gold medals in
female swimming once he decided that he
was a she and then everyone bowed down
to it and the feminists of the day were
applauding literally a woman with a
penis and i'll
literally a woman with a penis it's also
stupid he still has a penis and he was
winning the women's uh
swimming events although here in florida
ryan desantis actually signed something
saying that the girl the actual girl who
came in second place got the silver
medal that she was the actual winner uh
but okay the point of this is that
something good is happening the video i
first showed you about this mother
stepping up and saying no california
must fight against this good sign then
that the swimming organization is saying
no there are obviously biological
differences between boys and girls we
know this it's just true
guys are generally stronger than women
women are generally more nurturing than
dudes it's just how it is and it's okay
nature nurture hunter gatherer okay
basic stuff you guys all get it but
what's interesting
is how this is constantly being pushed
by the media and why is it constantly
being pushed by the media well we've got
some stuff from the televised mental
institution known as msnbc no trans
women um is this a a solution in search
of a problem i really think that's
what's going on here there is not some
grand existential threat to women's
sports caused by trans women's
participation the grand existential
threat to women's sports is not putting
women's sports on tv basically and not
supporting them so i think that you know
we have this one woman leah thomas who
has unfortunately become the face of a
problem that doesn't really exist um and
and she's she's being used as uh as a
peg in in these culture wars that we're
seeing around this country and around
the world
i mean just the way they use language
she's not a she that that is a
person who says that they are a woman
who still has male genitalia and shows
them in the locker room that's what one
of the other female actual female
competitors said
it's not not a problem just because it
right now it's mostly focused on him or
whatever the hell you want to say if
that doesn't make it not a problem that
actually is a problem it's the beginning
of a problem and why is it that the
feminists the tolerant progressive
feminists who were supposed to love
women
isn't that one of the things women are
oppressed the patriarchy man it's coming
to get you so why is it that the
feminists are actually against women
could it possibly be because the entire
woke progressive industrial complex is a
load of [ __ ] designed to confuse you
so ultimately they could control you
could it be that or is it just that they
really are into chicks with penises
beating women in swimming
there's a sentence i've never said
before
and of course the idea here that somehow
leah thomas is the victim and we should
have real sympathy for him and that
whole thing just complete nonsense but
all of this continues throughout the
mainstream media i saw this headline
from cnbc yesterday this is a humdinger
of a headline i can't win in this market
why
lgbtq homebuyers say mortgage rates are
hitting them especially hard
it's also written by a guy named james
pound
weiner
the guy weiner is the one that wants to
chop off the wiener and get them into
cali and then a guy named james pound is
telling you during gay pride month about
the how it's hitting gay people
especially hard i mean what the this is
we're in a simulation we really are in a
simulation um i am fairly certain that
there are no special interest rates for
gay people
i just bought a house i was not informed
i'm going to have to talk to my business
manager i was not informed that gay
people
get a special interest rate
i was not offered any sort of special
interest rate they didn't quiz me on
gayness to get a special interest rate
so the these headlines this is all it's
all just absolutely insane but not only
okay so you get it the trans stuff is
insane but they're also mixing all of
this of course with the race stuff right
because this is all they got this is all
they got if you don't bow to their trans
agenda you're a transphobe if you don't
bow to their race agenda you're a racist
uh well we've got more we've got more
because i don't know if you know this
but monday was juneteenth
which is now a federal holiday thanks to
joe biden i did not know it was a
federal holiday and i tried to do a wire
transfer on friday that apparently got
delayed and then one of my contractors
didn't get paid and now i got a freaking
uh stair step a big set of stairs
downstairs but no railing on it sidebar
uh here's the televised mental
institution known as mvc
with a panel of women talking about how
they're oppressed
how do we get our hair and makeup
together back in the news business your
beautiful hair
would not have been allowed even five
years ago
i went renegade last year and started
wearing every kind of braid style
let me tell you when i did it when that
crown act passed in new york yeah i'm
gonna wear all the different kinds of
gray as black women every single thing
about us is politicized and criminalized
that's right as we were having this
conversation about black hair
and i know everyone keeps saying that
we're in the midst of a national
reckoning you know i'm still waiting for
that i think honestly what i think is
more accurate is to say that we've been
in the midst of an awakening right um
but the reckoning for me will be when we
codify the value of black lives in our
budgets and in our policies
i mean it's just all such pure nonsense
it's like man these these are basically
all rich people who are on television
who have whatever they want who got in
all the makeup they want had their hair
done up however they want they are not
being criminalized nobody is coming for
them they are being elevated by the
culture by mainstream media by the rest
of the nonsense and by the way if
they're complaining about makeup okay
look i've got a little extra shine on my
forehead today okay can i get a little
powder up in here can i you see okay can
i get a little something on the cheeks a
little that would be that a little i got
a little i feel like i'm a little uh
that
see white guy i can get powder whenever
i want that's uh that's the point it's
just
such endless insanity but let's keep
going you want to keep going on the
insanity train once you're on the
insanity train that's the thing once you
are on the msnbc trained to bonkersville
it's hard to get off that train here's
joy reid talking to our vice president
who is one broken hip away from being
the most powerful person in the world
about uh katanji brown jackson
and uh her hearings when the republicans
were being very very mean to her
obviously because she's black
we all sat and watched the katanji brown
jackson hearings
in which she
very calmly um sat through what i think
a lot of particularly black women let's
just be honest felt was brazen
disrespect from senators like lindsey
graham senators like tom cotton senators
like josh hawley
what did you think when you watch that
hearing
i will tell you
joy
i experienced great
joy
when i watch this brilliant
phenomenal
black woman
jurist
be so smart
and just cut through
the political gamesmanship
that they were attempting to
incite
and she just was composed
and as far as i'm concerned was taking a
whole lot of people to school
those are clown people i don't care
about the color of their skin and i
don't care about their gender those are
not serious people those are ridiculous
people that woman should not be the vice
president of the united states that
other person should not be on television
paid by a giant corporation to bring
news but she's very proud because she
was you know she was really great in the
face of all the racism and the mean
stuff that they said and all that and
she schooled them she's cooled them
we've got some video of the schooling
uh can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me
a definition
dave don't do that that selectively
edited video tape to make it seem like
she doesn't know what a woman is there
must be video of her schooling mean
people like white supremacist ted cruz
for example i'm i'm an hispanic man
could could i decide i was an asian man
would i have the ability to be an asian
man and challenge harvard's
discrimination because i made that
decision
senator i'm not able to answer your
question you're asking me about
hypotheticals and um
how you would assess standing if i if i
came in and said i have decided i
identify as an asian man
damn
yo she schooled cruz cruz is busted man
he's done he's out that's it she's
composed and she crow god
continuing on the train to crazy town
via msnbc ibram x kendy who is the
biggest race huckster in the entire
country a man who once said that he was
horrified when his son came home from
school thinking that he was a girl even
though he pretends to be an
intersectional king
he was on joe scarborough's program joe
scarborough of course the total fraud
we've illustrated that quite effectively
over the last couple weeks here they go
talking about well racism
so tell tell everybody why you wrote the
book
well i wrote the book because the the
more that i that i researched
uh
this issue about race and children the
more that i continued on as a father
the more i realized that kids are
actually the most vulnerable
to racism
but with but they're the ones who were
least likely to engage about it and so i
wanted to write a book that would allow
parents and teachers and caregivers to
figure out ways to protect our children
from these simplistic messages like dark
is ugly and light
you know is good according to scholars
by three years old our kids have an
adult-like concept of race by three
years old our kids are attaching
qualities like smartness and honesty and
cleanliness
to skin color
nobody's doing that dude you're a
fraud
i dropped the f-bomb there it was going
to happen um you're just a complete
fraud like everyone that's ever met a
three-year-old they don't care about any
of this stuff you then by introducing
race to everything with them create a
new generation of racists right you're
creating these
soft racists and they're not these
racists this new generation of race
obsessed whack jobs that you're creating
and these woke lunatics uh they're not
old-school racists like i don't want a
black person to be at the same water
fountain as me which of course everyone
would think is wrong and there is
literally nobody in america in any
capacity in any influential capacity
that would want anything like that or
laws that would differentiate between
the races except for you guys you guys
who have decided that race should matter
when it comes to college admission you
guys who have decided race should matter
when it comes to hiring and who gets on
tv and who gets what award and all of
this stuff so what dave is the silver
lining you've been taking us on the
train to woke hell this entire show
save me dave well nobody's buying any of
this nonsense anymore and they can't
hide that right nobody's buying any of
this and this stuff which is being
pushed through the elderly man who's
pretending to be president who almost
broke his hip the other day joe biden uh
well they can't hide the fact that
nobody's listening to him anymore either
and uh here is uh cnn's john harwood
he's a democrat activist who pretends to
just be a non-partisan commentator uh
and he's uh defending joe biden's mental
capacity
so where are biden's critiques of the
media legitimate where are they
justified and where would you say
they're not justified
well look let's talk about the age thing
uh to begin with that you mentioned mark
libovich's column martin
you know top writer for the atlantic
saying biden should not run for
re-election it's not just sean hannity
talking about biden's age it's the
atlantic magazine that's right on the
other hand what's false is that he is
not capable of doing the job right now
or he's not mentally uh in tune with the
demands of the job
anybody any aide who engages with him or
reporters we can see this the gears of
his mind are working that is uh that's
an issue uh pushed by uh right-wing
media but it's not correct
you know the thing is that they're so in
on it right they're so running their
protection racket that we all protect
each other that we make sure you can't
see the things that you can see
that they can't stop lying i think
that's really sort of where we're at
with all this thing so john harwood
they're saying that the gears of biden's
mind are working no they're not they're
not and as i always say i don't take any
great pleasure in that i wish that they
were even if i disagree with his
policies i would like to believe that
the president is mentally fit he
obviously isn't man i mean just watch
we'll show it again next week
we found a really great compilation they
took all of the greatest hits of that
disastrous
absolutely disastrous interview
that biden gave to jimmy kimmel the
other night he cannot finish a sentence
and kimmel knew it and kimmel saved him
several times by finishing his sentences
or throwing to commercial the guy can't
go off script and he has trouble reading
when he's on script that is just a fact
so now you john harwood you are lying
and by the way you see even the way that
stelter framed it there that there this
is really about biden's age no no one's
saying it's about age you can be 78 79
84 and and very very mentally competent
of course you can of course you can but
he is not that is just the reality of
the situation uh but again
you guys see it they don't want you to
see it and there's a lot more that you
see that they don't want you to see
we've got a bit more from cnn on what's
going on with the economy
secretary yellen who has the job you
once had
said this week that quote there is
nothing to suggest a recession is in the
works do you agree with that
no i don't you think a recession is in
the way i think that when in fl i think
when inflation is as high as it is right
now and unemployment is as low as it is
right now it's almost always
been followed within two years by
inflation by
all right so that's basically the former
treasury secretary saying that the
current treasury secretary uh is wrong
and i suspect that she probably is wrong
but don't worry about janet yellen
because as you guys know
she has hope there's no question that we
have
huge inflation pressures
that inflation is really our top
economic problem at this point and that
it's critical that we address it so
um i do expect i do expect inflation to
remain high although i very much hope
that it will be coming down now
well i hope so too
thank you janet yellen
sign the check janet yellen she hopes
that the economy won't completely crash
under her watch
but because you guys are seeing the
things in your day-to-day life
that are real and the media can't keep
hiding them some of it is leaking to
biden himself and uh he has a little
trouble
regulating his responses
even more likely than ever not the
majority of them aren't saying that come
on don't make things up okay
now you're sounding like a republican
politician i'm joking that was a joke
put all kin aside no i don't think it is
whatever joe it's just all meaningless
he says one thing he means the other
it's a joke it's not it's just nothing
it's just nothing the point of today's
show is that you see stuff don't
not see what you see because they don't
want you to see it you know what i mean
see it know that it's happening know
that they're pushing this nonsense on
you know that you're not alone know that
reality exists that gender exists that
math exists that good exists that bad
exists know all that stuff and and we we
will get to the other side of this this
is just that weird state that we're in
right now before the midterms post covet
all of these all of this stuff this
weird thing where the mainstream media
is collapsing the online world is rising
like all these things we're just in this
weird amorphous place and it and some
days it feels really great some days it
feels really weird there's always more
bizarreness
but man know some basic truths and
you're going to be right we got a great
cold clothes for you but before we get
to that we are taking comments today
from rumble rants and from the locals
community sweetwater
says there is a golden girls episode
where slaves are mentioned i'm glad the
woksters have not caught that one yet
why why would you have me read that now
now some freak over at media matters and
they watch this show and they watch with
a fine toothed comb and they're
penciling down every single thing i say
they're going to go into all 170
episodes of the golden girls
seven brilliant seasons each season
getting better than the next would you
agree conor i've got connor watching all
the golden girls right now where where
are you at what season
season oh you've slowed down man you
gotta if you get past season four tell
you that's where it gets more body and
ridiculous the outfits are better yeah
um
i didn't there's a reference to slavery
like yeah well of course i mean blanche
was from the old south so there's a lot
of that blanche's father big daddy
there's some racist undertones there
should big daddy be canceled is that
what we're gonna do but really think
about it they removed betty freaking
white they took betty white off an
episode of the golden girls that just
doesn't exist anymore it's a hilarious
episode that actually is anti-racist in
the true sense of anti-racism because
dorothy's son is marrying a black woman
and at the beginning there's all this
tension which mostly has to do with the
fact that the black woman is much older
than her young son it doesn't even have
to do with race but then at the end they
get married and it's all good it's all
good
ridiculous kathy says i think leah
thomas was the straw that broke the
camel's back the ncaa swimming
championship was a joke and everyone saw
it yeah you know sometimes you need one
that is just so freaking obvious right
you need one that is like you know you
see something where you see the size of
him versus the the real girls or you see
the uh the time lapsed video of the race
did you see that i think we played it
once right where you just see him just
like this like ping pong and the girls
are just swimming as hard as they can
but girls are a little slower than men
it's why most of the guys in the nba are
men
there you go
sw says my program oh this is funny my
pronouns are m-a-g-a
ma
you get it there you go there you go uh
all right guys uh for more if you'd like
to play along during the show you go to
reuben
report.locals.com and as i said we will
keep an eye on rumble rants going
forward i will be in miami on july 14th
you can go to daveruba.com events if you
would like to join me part one of my
interview with devin nunes former
republican congressman from california
who is now running truth social is up
right now and i thought we'd cold close
it with a little throwback to the
elderly man pretending to be president
see you tomorrow you cannot go to a
7-eleven
or a dunkin donuts unless you have a
slight indian accent it's a fully am i'm
not joking